oh yes
every step of the way thank you last
weekend the overwatch league hosted its
first ever home games and that was the
sound of passionate engaged fans fans
that the o WL and eSports are lucky to
have
[Music]
so last weekend the first o WL homestand
weekend took place in Dallas with the
Dallas fuel hosting their first ever
home games about 5,000 people give or
take showed up each day and by all
metrics the whole thing was a big
success Blizzard has been teasing a
fully geo-located league which means
teams named after cities actually
playing in those cities since the
beginning of o WL since before it
started and this is the closest we've
ever come to having that dream become a
reality and the fans were [ __ ] high
[Applause]
we were loud they were passionate and
yes they booed specifically the hometown
crowd for the Dallas fuel boots some of
the incoming away teams including most
notably the LA valiant but also the
Houston L lost the boos were so loud
that the Dallas fuel players said they
could hear them through their headsets
in a recent interview now I like to
think most of you guys out there are
pretty reasonable intelligent people and
you understand that the booing that took
place is a good thing but not everyone
feels that way and it's prompted a
discussion on social media about whether
booing in eSports under any
circumstances is okay this is a
perspective the perspective that booing
isn't okay that I don't understand I
don't condone and I don't sympathize
with now I'm not saying the people who
think that aren't entitled to their own
opinion but their opinion is wrong
because this kind of passion which can
take the form of cheering it can take
the form of booing and jeers is
unobjective ly good thing not just for
the overwatch league but for eSports as
a whole not to get too philosophical
about it but for the O WL to exist for
this artificial competitive gaming
eSports ecosystem to function profitably
and continue to go on people have to
give a [ __ ] and giving a [ __ ] often
means wanting one team to win and the
other to lose the more fans boo the more
the overwatch League stands to benefit
because booing and jeering and cheering
are signs of emotional investment an
emotional investment is absolutely
necessary to get butts in metaphorical
and physical seats to sell merchandise
and to attract sponsorships now I've
seen a few comments here and there that
the booing that that negative emotional
energy could be bad for the financial
side of the league and man is that a
really bad take think about it do you
think the organizations behind the New
England Patriots or the Philadelphia
Flyers who anteed up twenty million
dollars to be in this thing want a group
of bland neutral fans robotic League
golf clapping
for every team indifferently I don't I
don't necessarily want to keep comparing
eSports
to traditional sports because I really
do think they're apples and oranges in
some ways but think about how absurd it
would be if you went to a professional
sporting event say a New England
Patriots game or an NBA game and the
fans were cheering equally for both
teams and we all hope that they just
went out there and tried their best and
had fun
it's a [ __ ] absurd idea blizzard
obviously wants to model the o WL after
traditional sports leagues I mean they
have city based teams they have whole
min away games and the whole broadcast
style even has sort of a pro sports feel
to it and if they want something akin to
a traditional sports league they're
going to have to take the cheers the
jeers and the boos that come along with
home-field advantage and disadvantage
now if you want proof of this we don't
even have to look at traditional sports
take a look at Counter Strike where
crowds can make or break big land events
take I am Sydney for example which is
actually going on right now funny enough
there's a reason it's more than just
another two hundred and fifty thousand
dollar tournament it's because the crowd
is [ __ ] wild a similar situation
happens when CS teams travel to Brazil
the crowd is very loud and very
passionate and sometimes very
controversial which gives mi BR and
other Brazilian teams very real home
field advantage --is now some of you who
aren't familiar with that particular
situation might be saying to yourselves
well gee why is that a good thing that
the fans in Brazil were the fans in
Australia gets so rowdy gets so crazy
can even affect the game because it
gives the competition a little extra
edge a little atmosphere when you walk
into those stadiums it's different it
feels special it's exciting for the fans
and in the moment the players may be a
little frustrated but believe me there's
reason why they take that 12-hour flight
to Australia for Sydney or the same
thing for Brazil these are special
events with special crowds with
home-field advantage we can also look to
csgo for examples of how real
professionals handle being on the other
side of the booze they were not always
cheering for us but we came here for the
passion we saw the passion and will come
back for sure
it was very crazy and I was smiling
throughout the day because these guys
are so crazy man you can't compare to
anything hopefully when we come back to
Copenhagen our Danish fans will will
give something back to MIT ah it was
crazy today I hope we come back it's a
great city great crowd we love you when
you hit the big leagues so to speak part
of being a professional is performing at
your pink at your best when things are
less than ideal from a peace and quiet
perspective some players thrive on it
I mean this crowd has been immense all
the way through these grand finals
obviously there is a day in playing on
phase how much does that home land
advantage make a difference for them
against you you guys can make a choice
tomorrow you either cheer for escape or
we're gonna turn this place in library
again at the end of the day guys booing
is actually an incredibly positive sign
for the overwatch League it shows that
fans are passionate that they're
emotionally invested and then they give
a [ __ ] about their home teams and that
bodes well for the future of this
eSports league far as I'm concerned I
can't wait for there to be more booze
more jeers and more trash talk in the
overwatch League and eSports as a whole
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]